you looked at like okay jeffrey dahmer  i love him  was his mom crazy  what do you know about his parents i  know that the dad like stopped by him  but i don't know about anything about  his mother no she was you kind of have  to look at the parents and be like okay  because there's a lot of serial killers  whose parents are like i don't know what  happened you know totally yeah it's  always a midwestern parent  no idea what happened he was feign  [Laughter]  killing people yeah yeah his dad and i  are so upset  [Laughter]  i know people who are and angels  angels of the planet  and they're kids but there was a point  angels carving  satan symbols their skin